take a look at this here article this is
from bloomberg
city lab speaking of bloomberg dozens of
city governments declare racism a public
health crisis
okay that literally means nothing but
sure more than 50 city declarations put
racism's health impacts on par with
disease and addiction
health organizations and school
districts are adopting them too
do you know what the cure for racism is
stop talking about it no no i mean like
stop calling stop calling people by
their
their race just calling them a person no
no no i'm talking about
it's a public health crisis adam the
government has said so
that's how you know how do you think
they will seek to cure this public
health crisis
i don't know where where is this anyway
50 different cities and this is from the
13th so it's ignoring the fact that
colorado state
has already pushed for the declaration
itself and a bunch of other cities in
the meantime
and this and about 10 or 12 percent of
the cdc
has signed a document demanding the cdc
declare
a racism a public health emergency in
this country heaven help us
nationwide let me guess biden will save
us all from it
no lyden's for it no i know he's for it
that's
that's what my point is right tim come
on yes
i thought you meant save us like like
the in in the honest sense of what
saving us means
not from their perspective so this is
what you're gonna get
so your friend who says like i don't
know what you're talking about i'll tell
you what
there's gonna be some dude who shows up
in a pink you know shirt that says
community police
and they're gonna knock on your door and
they're gonna say we heard you last
night playing rap music
you're under arrest you have to come
with us and they're going to be able to
arrest
how can they arrest anyone what do you
mean morality policing i know but
who's going to they don't have authority
to arrest people is that
they're going to have authority to do
that the new police so they're going to
they're going to think that they can
take somebody against their will you
think someone
who doesn't want to get taken is going
to allow that to happen i absolutely no
i do case in point the mccloskeys who
handed over their guns
illegal that when the police illegally
seized them yes when the state
authorities show up at their door
and say um you culturally appropriated
and that's a violation of the law
look if they can get the city council to
vote to abolish the police
they're gonna do a whole bunch of crazy
things that that's a bad example dude
what is the maklowski's were law-abiding
citizens
they even knew that those guns weren't
fire firing right they couldn't be fired
and so you're you're giving an example
of a law-abiding citizens well of course
they're gonna go along with it
i'm not talking about those people i'm
talking about the people that are
actually doing crimes
that don't care i just said the person's
at their house playing rap music
okay and a guy shows up in a pink shirt
and says you're under arrest for
cultural appropriation yeah well
who who knows the type of person i mean
anyone can listen to rap music i listen
to rap music
the point there's there's people that
that won't care who shows up they'll be
like
get out of here f off if the maclaw
slammed the door who done it to
republicans and show up on their porches
with within us with a with a with a
rifle
pointing you know and and the wife with
the handgun
if they're willing to do that and
they're still willing to turn over their
weapons
to an illegal demand if the adolescent
owners
who are saying you can't force us are
still willing to get in the police
vehicle with the cops and be arrested
more law-abiding citizens and a guy
playing rap music is also a law-abiding
citizen
and when the unconstitutional edicts
come down and racism is a public health
crisis
and just like covid they can
unconstitutionally lock down your
business and arrest you
they're going to say to cure racism we
must end white supremacy
you can't play this music and then they
show up and say you're under arrest and
the people will say
okay they've been doing it why would
they stop
the only evidence we have right now
based on everything that's happened is
that people will
absolutely agree to all of the
unconstitutional edicts laid before them
right now the world economic forum has
announced the new program to be
implemented will take your blood i'm not
making this up yeah it's crazy i'm not
going to give him my blood and guess how
many people will
a lot if if the world health if the
world economic forum can straight come
out and say if you would like to go to
arenas
and go to the movies and travel you must
go to a lab and give them your blood
and they will they will then give you a
mobile app which will confirm
you're free to travel and that's in the
public
certified news guard confirmed from the
world economic forum
and there's no rioting over this i don't
think people care
if i don't know about it like no one
knows about that
i didn't hear about that until you just
told me well now they do
i'm i'm about to riot dude so that's
ridiculous so no one's gonna take my
blood and tell me i can't go
travel because they have to analyze my
blood bro they shut down your passport
already you've done well then i'm going
to leave this country then if that's the
case why would i want to be in this
country
your passport's been voided you can't
travel anywhere anymore dude
well it sounds like it's time for us to
riot because this is ridiculous
the left the left gets to riot so if if
they get to riot because of this stuff
why
i mean i'm this is insane like i i i'm
starting to get really i was already mad
when they arrested you're telling me
that that's what that's what their new
plan is
then we we need to to to start freaking
protesting and riot man i'm down let's
do this
not riot well whatever don't work well
it seems like they're
it's legal legally they're getting
things done
we've been talking about you've been
talking about right now your point right
right
backfires look at this
this is this is because they're rioting
and no it's getting into this the riots
helped donald trump that's why they
panicked and backed off immediately
okay donald trump sent out police and
people started supporting him
peaceful protests do work people
standing up and linking arms around
statues does work
coming out and saying i won't stand for
this works telling your boss you won't
stand for it works
people doing everything they can all
right if that's the case then let's get
this tell them it's not gonna work
they're not gonna take our blood let's
fight this everybody needs to fight this
we got 40 000 people here if you
if you want your blood taken and and
have them analyze it and allow you to go
to the movies allow you to travel
shut down your passport because you
haven't given your blood if that's not
ridiculous to you
then let it happen pull it up world
economic forum
let me just make sure you see this news
guard certified this website adheres to
basic standards of credibility and
transparency
transparency 82.5 out of 100.
could this covet 19 health passport be
the future of travel and events
and here's the machines that actually do
it you're given your phone you get a qr
code
and they say straight up that let me see
where it is they say specifically blood
tests boom this is from the united
nations this is not america
it's the city right there it's the world
economic forum okay
yes and they're doing this around the
world
this is what they're calling for right
now covid pass the brainchild of the
world economic forum's young global
leaders mustafa mukash
it also involves ygls across five
continents including muna
abu suleiman and peggy lu covid pass
uses blockchain technology to store
encrypted data from individual
blood tests allowing users to prove
they've tested negative for covet 19.
so will that come to the united states
maybe not but it also means our
passports don't work anymore and we
can't go anywhere
there's like what are there like four
countries we can travel to now
i don't know yeah there's like four
that's that's insane if you don't have a
passport what are you how are you
supposed to leave the us
you can't that's the point right you
can't you can't go anywhere anymore
so there's there's a small i think we
can go to turkey
mexico and a couple other countries not
even canada right there was a private
jet full of ultra wealthy people
that tried flying to uh europe and got
turned away and had to fly somewhere
else
yeah we can't go to canada either holy
cow and guess what the rich people are
going to do
they're going to buy a saint kitchen
nevis passport for 50 000
and then whatever they want they're
going to buy citizenship because you can
it's called economic citizenship right
you got a rich person got half a million
bucks
you drop that in a bank account in some
country boom you're a citizen you go
wherever you want
now they'll probably want your blood i
guess because that's what the world
economic forum is talking about
but let me go back to this this point
about all of the
racism as a public health crisis listen
if they're telling us straight up what
what whiteness
is and white supremacy and it's a public
health crisis
hey the same as covid and they violated
the constitution
to arrest business owners in new jersey
in texas
and ohio and and this was
months ago they arrested the patron of a
gym in new jersey
and there's been there have been some
back the blue protests
but there hasn't been widespread outrage
in terms of
you know on par with what we've seen
from black lives matter in fact the left
doesn't seem to care all this is going
on
so i'll tell you what i'm seeing we have
seen absolutely
zero evidence to suggest that well
i take that back i would say we have
seen a tiny
tiny morsel to suggest that people will
resist unconstitutional edict
and in this the police will absolutely
adhere to their orders
over the constitution the two guys at
adolescent who said
no these are people this is evidence to
suggest some people will stand up and
remain defiant
someone sent me a um some a law that was
put into place a long time ago i think
in like 1986 or something
and it allows the president to take
control of
um and basically turn all the police
force into a po
i don't remember the exact words
something about a posse something
so he he can actually take control of
them all theoretically under directive
51
as well but it was before director 51
even came into
into place so he can enact that and and
enact the other thing
so it's like if they're going to follow
their orders technically it would be
following the orders if the president
ordered them to do something
if he if he actually would do it i know
so
listen the point i'm making is if all of
these cities and states
colorado now are saying racism is a
public health crisis
well cultural appropriation is racist so
yeah
white men playing rap music they'll come
to your house and tell you to stop
you can't do that they'll they'll
they'll come to your job and say no more
schedules allowed other ridiculous
nonsense
who knows how absurd and insane they'll
get but we also what happened with
evergreen and brett weinstein
they they they shut everything down they
they locked the administrators in their
rooms they wouldn't let them go to the
bathroom
and when the guy was talking and he was
waving his hands they said stop waving
at their hands it's racist and when he
did they all laughed at him
it's the rise of authoritarianism and
they're using this to push it through
and all of these people are cheering for
it in massive protests
and the silent majority is crossing
their fingers that voting for trump will
fix it
maybe maybe but these cities are doing
this right now
and the progressives have already said
do whatever you want
even if we lose we are here forever
that's what some of these they were
tweeting it earlier a bunch of
progressives were like we're here to
stay it's not going away
so i wonder about these cities where
these declarations were put into effect
i wonder about these specific instances
but more importantly i wonder about
when andrew cuomo put sick people into
nursing homes killing
and i mean this quite literally killing
he personally killed
6500 people were there riots
nope now when a guy in
ferguson just blows me away try i tell
that to people and they don't even
believe me
they're they they get upset because
actually someone
completely blocked me because i just
simply said that
because i was talking about the numbers
and i'm like well what about the fact
that he killed
thousands of people and then i didn't
even get a response it just got i just
got blocked
it's like oh wow okay you just want to
live in that blindness
and considering there are people who
don't believe it i pulled up the source
pro
publica is is a left-wing publication
okay they probably would say they're
legitimate journalism they say
the cuomo administration hasn't said
which nursing homes were infected with
covet 19
after its order sent positive patients
into them dozens of new york nursing
homes didn't see their first coveted
case until sick patients were sent there
many under andrew cuomo state policy to
date six percent of the state's nursing
home population roughly roughly 6 500
residents have died
that's cuomo he did that yes he did
he's got blood on his hands what's his
approval rating at right now he was at
60
last time i checked wonderful his
approval rating is at 60 percent because
no one's talking about this though the
mainstream media
is not they're not talking about that
yep
so i have to wonder though is it if if
people
aren't standing up over all of these
things we've just talked about
is the message actually reaching a
silent majority or is
the silent majority silent because they
don't know
because the me because there's no yeah
maybe in which case they're not going to
vote for trump well you know what i'm
going to take this time to ask all of
you
to tell speak up talk about all the
stuff to everybody you know because this
is this we're losing our freedoms right
now
they're single-handedly taking all of
our freedoms away just keep taking
plucking them away
one by one just gone gone gone gone so
unless you want to live
with no freedoms you get you better
start standing up for yourselves
a lot of people are coming up to me and
saying that they're speaking up and it's
awesome
and i i love it i love it so much it's
that's what i want to see that's what we
need to do we need to speak up
and and and fight this because
they're doing it in front of our eyes
and we're just sitting there like
they're not going to do they're not
going to make it worse are they
they're not going to make it well nope
they just made it worse yep racism is a
cultural appropriation
is now illegal great awesome check this
out
bloomberg says among the causes for the
declaration as stated in the resolution
a quote a failure by any of our citizens
to acknowledge the prevalence of racism
in our community and join in the fight
to eradicate its effects on the majority
of our residents
is an unwelcome option that's memphis
what does that mean okay so this is like
what joe jorgensen was talking about
when she gave that
libertarian tweet about being
anti-racist
this is not passively not being racist
this is actively
taking the steps that they want you to
take this is just authoritarianism
join the cult 100 the the libertarian
party candidate
told people what they must do
when the churches are are shutting down
when the supreme court straight up said
we will infringe upon your right to
freedom of religion
yep where were the religious folk unless
it's
anybody you know did you see you know
the funeral that went on the other day
was
messed up yep that's right they were
sitting right next to each other
no masks packed the whole place in and
obama was like we
we can't have these big open events or
we can't have these big events of people
all close to each other
wink wink right they had a funeral
they had a funeral is for john lewis
right yeah and uh you know rest in peace
my respects
yet they had a funeral where they're all
sitting next to each other
and they flaunt it they are the cultural
authority
yeah and it's as simple as the far left
will go up they'll go out they'll
protest
and no one else will now not to be fair
i'm exaggerating a bit there are back
the blue protests that go outside and
there there have been many across this
country
but they're they're they're not nearly
as big as black lives matter was
yep black lives matter is more popular
according to various polls than both
political parties right now
and we we've seen high-profile leaders
of the organization say that they should
form their own political party because
they'd win
they probably would yeah and then look
at herman cain
they're just trying to to make it seem
like he went to a trump event
and got coveted well news flash he was
tested
before and after going to that and
didn't have it
so he didn't get it there he was also
fighting cancer for a lot for
over two years you know it's like sure
he did he caught it sure okay and and
happened to die but he was
his body wasn't a hundred percent stage
four cancer
yeah you know it's like and they're just
they're politicizing his death because
he was not on their side he wasn't one
of their
their uh soldiers so they're not
propping him up at all when he was an
awesome man
disgusting who was it who uh denied was
it de blasio denied the blue lives
matter mural
yeah they are flaunting their violations
of the constitution yes they are
straight up flaunting it yup if
it has gotten so extreme in the past
several months this year
where these people violent
authoritarians
engaging in repressive violent behavior
empowering their cronies map painting
their messages in the streets
and denying equality to others while
simultaneously trying
to revoke civil rights legislation at
least in california
which it'll come next to the federal
government i assure you and it'll come
under the guise of probably like trans
rights i'd imagine
something that effect what they're doing
in california is under the guise of
affirmative action
they want to hire based on race they're
stripping away our rights
and they've already been taking them
away it's it's it's
it's freedom's sure but it's our civil
rights
our right to life liberty and pursuit of
happiness is gone under covet it is gone
100 yep seems like it these governors
are crushing industry crushing
businesses
and there you go and what do we get
internationally
they are calling for quite literally our
blood
yeah you're right well they're calling
for our blood
nope isn't it against some religions it
is
yeah yeah it's like how are they gonna
get around that well you can't
accept blood i'm not sure if you can not
give it no there's some religions where
you can't get your you can't pierce your
own skin
at all like that's against people's
religion
well i don't the freedoms are being
taken away right in front of our eyes
yeah dude
it's like people people are like well
why don't you run for office it's like
i'm sitting here talking about this
i'm telling you guys i'm i i'm yeah some
people say i get emotional but
i i you should be too you should be mad
this is insane it's happening right in
front of our eyes
if you're not mad then what is wrong
with you we all are why are you laughing
it's not even funny
if you're not mad you're not paying
attention thank you that's the saying
that's why i laugh because it's true
100 percent you should be mad about this
this should be something that you care
about and i don't think people care
about it anymore because i think life is
too easy
honestly i don't know how else to put it
we've been really lucky this is what our
parents fought for and we should be
grateful
but at the same time why are we just
gonna let it go away
honestly is this really what we want if
you care about your kids then you should
do something
i can't find the travel map i was trying
to find the travel map that they've been
sharing i can't remember which source it
was
but it's a map of the earth and it's
like the countries
in blue are where you can travel to as
an american and there's like four
countries
so i was talking to my friend in ukraine
because
before you know the end of last year i
had actually went and hung out with her
in in mexico
and i was like man isn't it so great to
have an american passport
like it's it's it's so difficult for
people from other countries to travel
even even for for her to go to mexico
it's like you've got to get an
application or whatever
but they have like a new treaty and then
here i am with this golden ticket i can
fly wherever i want
and now eight nine months later you
can't go anywhere
it's it's it's like they're basically
telling us we have to fall in line with
their
with what they want or else conveniently
right as donald trump is running for
reelection it's it's you know
how fortunate or or unfortunate to be
honest because it may result in a and
such a massive backlash that trump wins
in a in a ridiculous landslide
i think that's going to happen
definitely but what's crazy about this
today
compared to the other landslides is that
the whole
world is involved with covet
the the entire planet i mean i guess
except sweden which kind of never did
anything
you know and their their deaths are
dropping yep
and their cases caseloads are dropping
yeah i was encouraged
i don't know all i know is since the
start of this
it's been lie after lie there's a really
funny post going viral on reddit right
now
where it's uh you do you know the uh the
subreddit m
iva hole i don't i don't read it there's
a very popular subreddit called am i the
a-hole where somebody
you know they use the real the the real
swear
but basically what you do is you say hey
today you know
my girlfriend made me pancakes and i
didn't eat them because
i had a stomachache and now she's upset
am i the a-hole it's like that's how it
works
typically the stories are a bit more
complicated than that where they'll say
something like
i bought tickets to an island vacation
without consulting my wife it was a
surprise
then it turns out she really hates you
know this you know islands and she's
upset
am i the a-hole and one of them was
it said i made my kid wear a mask to
school even though the school mandated
he not be allowed to wear it
am i the a-hole and they all said yes
why are you teaching your kid to be
paranoid why are you telling your kid to
wear masks don't you know wearing masks
is wrong you're so dumb
and it was from four months ago wow yeah
four months ago
they said you're an a-hole if you wear a
mask
wow they your nail if you don't and what
are we seeing
you know what man there was a guy eating
lunch with his wife
and they had masks they took them off to
eat their food and the lady got mad and
she sprayed them
there was another story of a guy who was
he took off his mask to eat i think a
banana
and some guy start splashed him in the
face with coffee so he punched the other
guy in the face
like all over masks so since the
beginning of this we've seen a violation
of our rights
businesses have been illegally shut down
people have been arrested for running
their businesses
and that's it carry on it's like is the
world ending or something
is the simulation over the is the meteor
the alien's gonna be here and like we
gotta
they're like quick everybody put on your
best uniform everybody get in line
because aliens are gonna land i have no
idea what's going on but i'll tell you
this no it's simple tim
they need to get trump out of office so
they don't all go to jail
[Laughter]
i think you're right that is the simple
solution man i'm dead serious
that's all it is we're gonna go to jail
unless we uh no not
us the people that are making this all
happen tonight that's what they're
saying
yep they're like uh what do we do we're
we're getting called out
we need this to all to go away trump is
not doing it because he's after us
and yeah they're uh
they're scared and they should be
because trump's gonna win
and they're going to go to jail i
believe yeah but don't you think
don't you think they'd go a bit above
and beyond
cheating uh what do you think
2020 is dude it's the cheat year yeah
this is is this not above and beyond
tim all right to me so so here's the big
question then
if november 4th rolls around and
they say joe biden won what do you do
let's say it's like voting went off
without a hitch joe biden wins in a
landslide donald trump says
i lost everybody joe biden immediately
comes out and says the durham
investigation is over
done on the 20th the day i'm inaugurated
i am putting an end to all of this
all of trump's policies erased ah you
know what i'm gonna do if that's the
case
crack open some whiskey the only thing i
can do
you know what i would do you know what i
would do what would you do i would get
out my little ballot at the next
election and i would vote someone's butt
into office who would help hold him
accountable
that would be the only thing i could do
i couldn't condone rioting
everything would be gone no writing
doesn't work that's the issue right
everything would be gone
any any evidence that that's there
is gone if if he gets into public if
that's come on you know what i think man
they didn't think trump was gonna win so
they didn't clean shop clean up house i
know
i know so they were like i'm imagining
you know obama doing the obama gate
stuff with biden and michael flynn
and they're like or you know before this
before trump actually won
should we uh should we burn these
documents no trump can't win it's fine
then trump wins they're like oh geez
they had an insurance
policy yeah they did peter strzok and
lisa page
fbi agents talking about their insurance
policy to stop trump from winning
yep and then straight up saying don't
worry he's not going to let him win
we won't let him yep that's that's on
the record
what did you say like thank god or
something i don't know exactly that but
that's she did say that
didn't she get hired didn't she get
hired by msnbc she is a commentator now
yeah yeah yep so so is mccabe
so i don't know i don't know man i'm not
100 convinced
that all of this goes away if trump wins
i just know that joe biden can't
i he can't win nope no i mean it's and
it's beyond all of this insanity that's
been happening around the country
it's the fact that if you remove all
that from the equation you've got
a creepy dude who gropes little girls
who falls asleep on tv
okay who in their right mind would vote
for this man i have no idea i don't
understand the people then
not to mention his his history of bills
that he's put up
and and the racist stuff that like he's
literally racist like
did you hear what all of the the
different oh goodness another thing
great what about how
people can't distinguish he basically
said all asians look the same
oh my gosh and i i said hey hey hey whoa
whoa that's not true man well in this
instance you're just white
in in this sense right of course because
he ain't black
the fact that he would say something as
insanely racist as
he basically said that when trump
criticizes china it's racist because the
average person can't tell the difference
in his mind that's ridiculous between
like someone from south korea or china
yes and that's one of the one of the
most insane things
it's like the dudes never actually
traveled or met any of these
people but he actually says this and
they're like that's right joe
like why would you agree with this man
that's not true i don't i don't
understand anyone that supports that guy
yep they anyone that supports him all i
can think is
you're misinformed oh cute oh that's sad
that's where i'm at right now you know
what i hear from my people on the left
when they're like
when i talk about the guy throwing the
explosive for instance they're like
tim's lying he won't talk about the
peaceful protests and i was like
there was a peaceful protest and then a
bunch of people started throwing
explosives
so that's the story right what do you
want me to say you want me to
you want me to lie and remove the
explosives part
yes they do that's what they literally
do during occupy wall street
i would film anything cop protester or
otherwise i just filmed what was going
on
i actually had them physically threaten
me that i needed to stop filming them or
else
the reason they tried taking a light
approach was because i was getting a ton
of attention for them
so long as it was beneficial they were
happy
recently i had this antifa guy tell me
that
back in the day when we used to talk
about the rights of freedom of
expression liberalism free speech etc
they were using me
they knew that as long as i was hanging
out with them and was friends with them
people were more likely to see a
positive view of them and the moment
that
you know that camp broke up and i left i
was absolutely their enemy
so during occupy many of them physically
attacked me this is what i love the most
when people comment on my post and
they're like tis
disked him condemning the activists what
happened to you since occupy and i'm
like
did you not remember that during occupy
wall street the the the antifa
type we called them we called them black
block were physically attacking me like
on numerous occasions
like there's video of it because i
filmed them breaking the law and i
yelled i will film you breaking the law
and you can't do anything about it
they've never liked me because i've
always been about transparency and
accountability
well they don't want that for themselves
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast we do the show
live
monday through friday at 8pm if you want
to catch the full show
tune in to this channel subscribe hit
the like button or
check us out on itunes and spotify and
we will soon have this podcast up for
free
on all podcast platforms thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all in the
next
episode
you